good afternoon everyone
sadly we are now now able to confirm
that yesterday we recovered Nicola Bully
from the river wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated
our thoughts are with them at this time
as well as with all her loved ones and
the wider community
we recognize the huge impact that
Nicholas disappearance has had on a
family and friends
but also on the people of Saint Michael
we would like to thank all of those who
have helped during what has been a
hugely complex and high emotional
investigation
today's development is not the outcome
any of us would have wanted
but we hope that at least it can begin
to provide some answers for Nicholas
loved ones
they remain foremost in our thoughts
the case is now being handled by his
Majesty's coroner